in ukrainian hubs we help ukrainians to  find temporary accommodation  so  all this  sphere of the  first aid in in  sheltering and this is our help now  we do it because we are ukrainians and  for us it is very important to help  people in need we were doing it before  the war and now there is a urgent need  to help people who are fleeing from the  war we couldn't do other way it's it's  also for us  emotionally we could not  sit not doing anything and be in  ukrainian organization in poland it's  our obligation another desire ukrainians  are now fighting not only for ukraine  but also for europe and we need help of  europe to protect ukraine and europe if  we will win if ukraine will win european  union also will win